so I recently had a question should I
work out when I'm fasting so let's talk
about that so many people have this idea
they have to eat before the exercise to
get energy for whatever reason so let's
first talk about the three or four
variables to exercise you have the type
of exercise you have the intensity of
the exercise how hard it you go and then
the duration how long you go and then
you have the recovery so the purpose of
exercise is to make you more fit to
increase the health of the system to
build more capacity more fitness to
actually have less stress there's many
benefits of exercise but those are some
of them so what you're doing is you're
stressing your body and then your body
is going to adapt to that and prove
various things you have to be careful
not to over train because overtraining
will inhibit your sleep keep your
inflammation up and reduce your gains so
it's always kind of a an adjustment of
figuring out what your optimum amount of
intensity duration and recovery is
if you overtraining let's say you only
give yourself a few hours to recover you
know you're not going to actually see
any change now in the recovery mode this
is when all the good things happen
glycogen reserve replenishment new
capillaries are grown new mitochondria
cell structures are repaired enzymes are
restored enzymes of the things that
actually do all the work in the body
lactic acid is cleared if you have too
much lactic acid in your body that your
body can't burn up because it can use
this as fuel it can create a condition
called lactic acidosis which can cause
Russ's leg syndrome
difficulty breathing in a whole series
of other symptoms I have videos on that
also you have the endocrine system
involved where you have a really good
spike of growth hormone which is
involved in improving not just muscle
growth but the growth of other proteins
and also repair in general of proteins
and another hormone that has increased
is called glucagon which is basically a
hormone that helps you burn more fat now
the problem is when you consume food
before you workout or you do
carbo-loading which I'm very much
against you decrease the amount of
growth hormone that you can produce you
potentially can increase too much lactic
acid in the body because glucose turns
into lactic acid and you actually
greatly diminish the ability to burn fat
because when you're actually eating the
body is going to be burning up those
dietary calories and not your own
calories
now when you fast you get this massive
additional increase of growth hormone
now think about it exercise triggers
growth hormone and fasting increases
growth hormone so when you combine them
you get a huge effect of growth hormone
and what's really cool about fasting is
you get amazing reparative action so you
have this huge spike in repair in
general so it's gonna actually be come
in handy when when your your body's
trying to repair from the stress so the
body can actually get new capillaries
mitochondria repair the cell structures
more efficiently when you workout during
the fasting mode you can enhance fat
burning by 20 to 30% more and also you
improve insulin resistance now a reason
why certain people consume carbs before
workout is they're trying to enhance the
spike of insulin to build more muscle
mass but here's the problem it also at
the same time creates insulin resistance
because the body does not like too many
carbs so the more insulin resistance you
have the less you're gonna absorb as far
as amino acids and proteins nutrition
but by doing fasting you develop a much
more sensitivity for insulin in general
and the insulin works a lot better so
you can actually pull in a more amino
acids and more nutrients I had one guy
who was working out he wanted to gain
more muscle mass and he was consuming a
certain amount of calories a lot of
carbs he went on keto in a minute
fasting he lost weight he wanted then
gained more weight but this time when he
did it healthily and he brought his
carbs up to about 50 to 60 grams per day
so he kind of maxed them out and still
being on keto he
started to develop more muscle growth
because of this one fact that he
improved instant resistance when before
he was doing the certain amount of
calorie amount he was he wasn't able to
absorb the nutrients and protein now
with the same amount of calories
different foods not having instant
resistance he was able to start
absorbing these nutrients and that's
what created more muscle mass now as far
as the type of exercise this really
depends on your recovery so if your
recovery is poor you do aerobic exercise
low intensity walking something real
light and then you build up to more
anabolic which is more like
high-intensity interval training would
be very good compound resistance
exercise using as many muscles as
possible when you're working out high
intensity that would be very beneficial
to maximize your growth hormone
so in summary absolutely yes you want to
strive to exercise when you're fasting
because there are so many benefits
mainly for the reparative actions thanks
for watching if you're liking this
content please subscribe now and I will
actually keep you updated on future
videos